The Joe Rogan Experience people think
that my knees are bad from a lot of
running and they're wrong I'm I I wasn't
born healthy I wasn't born with some
great body alignment some great no I
have sickle cell I have all kind of [ __ ]
I have all kind of health issues you
know all kind of I'm [ __ ] up so I had
a choice to make and the choice was you
know growing up you know okay this hurts
that hurts we can just sit down and do
nothing
or we can see how far we can push the
human body
so on that Journey as I started getting
more and more into my mind and start
realizing that while what I'm capable of
doing
my mind got stronger so the so the pain
in my knees
while it sucked
I've been doing it for so long it was
like it became our new Norm like okay my
knees hurt
[ __ ] it stop you know and I called like
I'm stop feeling sorry for yourself but
you sometimes have to ignore your
feelings I'm gonna send Jamie a picture
you need oh no dude I I think Jamie has
some uh do you have a picture of his
knee Jamie did I ever send it to you
Jamie
I have it here hold on let me just but
keep going no so it's like
for for me I I made a decision and my
decision was to be
the best person I could
and I basically a lot more as I wake up
and say [ __ ] your feelings
and that doesn't mean like you know
don't take it literally [ __ ] your
feelings but sometimes you have to go
beyond what you're feeling and my knees
were [ __ ] but guess what I wanted to
run and I knew that okay you can get
knee Replacements this and that like I
said it wasn't because of Iran too much
people I was gonna say oh man you ran so
much so you [ __ ] up your body you know
you don't want to be like David Goggins
I hear all the time you won't be like
David Goggins but so there's your knee
yeah there it is for us look at the fact
that there's zero space between those
bones yes sir from the top from your
your your tibia to your femur there's
zero space it's just kneecap
covering two bones that are rubbing
against each other
and so
this was after surgery where they had to
cut your knee
slice your shin like in half and then
take a chunk out of it because it had
deformed so much from you running with
bone on bone that was starting to like
swell out in One Direction and it was
changing the alignment of your leg right
this happened back in 2000 2001 was
going through buds
so this happened for long this is this
right here has been going on for a long
time
so and it got to a point where it's like
okay
I'm done
and that's to play this in there right
now so as you see the wedge
that part right there in the bone that's
opened up yeah so they had to cut it
realign it and then um now the
alignment's better but this is now about
17 months ago 17 18 months ago when this
happened
so can they get some screws that fit go
back to that real quick
the one sticks right out of the [ __ ]
bone hey cut that [ __ ] off yeah find
that [ __ ] down is that thing sticking in
your leg no I don't well I feel the
plate every single time I move yeah so
every team so because it's like
connected to the hamstring so whenever I
[ __ ] whenever I move that plate is
very irritating so every step even like
when I walk when I run it's this very
irritating thing and then you gotta wait
for so long for that leg to start
getting back into place and if you see
that other picture I sent of the foam my
my foam leg that I put my hand in I
think Jennifer sent it to you Jamie with
the foam leg you'll see this in a second
this is [ __ ] up so like the swelling
in that leg
was [ __ ] nuts oh when you had edema
yeah you showed it to me in Vegas yeah
you were sticking your thumb into yours
I grabbed it yeah yeah so it was it was
pretty nuts but um you know once again
it's just things you uh things I was
willing to endure
right there
so that's just all post surgery swelling
yeah so when the doctor said this to you
and he he said look this is how [ __ ]
up your knee is did he say you need a
replacement what was he saying basically
I had two options so I went to the first
guy had the surgery done that's in the
book I talked about that
but then the second guy so after the
first surgery I was done so this is the
first surgery after buds no so this is
like back in uh looking at 2000 so me
and Cameron this is recently so I didn't
have any surgery going through buds
really I didn't have any surgery at all
so I went through in 2001 I [ __ ] it
2000 2001 whatever it was I messed up my
leg real bad and hell we kept on going
on it just kept on going what did you do
to it in hell week it was like I I
[ __ ] it up somehow like running or
whatever I have it and can't hurt me but
um it was uh
I think the boat I fell it twisted but
over a period of time it's got worse and
worse and worse so I was getting like
toward all shots every day
and then this got worse but I'm like
[ __ ] it I'm good so I kept going on it
so it kind of healed all [ __ ] up
so this kept going kept going kept going
years later
years later it's kept going on it so I
stopped squatting so it became like okay
my knees [ __ ] up my lime is messed up
my hips are messed up I can't squat so I
can still run so okay I started running
because running doesn't require you to
bend down and [ __ ] so I'm running a lot
and they got to
um 20 years later pretty much
and it was 2020 or if I don't get this
right Cameron Haynes came down and we
went for a 20 mile run
my knees were [ __ ] up for like 10
years long story short it was like okay
man I got to get this thing looked at
someone got looked at the doctor was
like oh we can go in there and just do a
quick little [ __ ] you know cleanup
job
and the cleanup job went so quick
guy was breaking tools and [ __ ] [ __ ]
up like literally broke tools and I have
it in there he was breaking too I talked
to him I know he told me your meniscus
was the hardest meniscus he's ever
experienced in his life he's like dude
he goes I didn't know that meniscus
could get that way he goes like he's not
human he goes when I was cutting into
meniscus it broke the scalpel yep Wilson
Jeremy said Wolf's lost something yeah
he said normally when you cut into
meniscus it just slices right through
like butter he's like I couldn't cut it
yeah mine went butter mine went but it's
all those [ __ ] who think I'm
putting them Hundred Mile weeks go [ __ ]
yourself [ __ ] you don't get no [ __ ]
like that babe I sit on the [ __ ]
couch no I mean that's the craziest
thing I've ever heard like you've
hardened your meniscus just through
constant pressure and pounding yeah so
he went in there to clean it up and then
what happened so basically that little
meniscus that whatever the [ __ ] was in
there so my so my alignment was so bad
the only thing
that was keeping me able to do anything
was that little [ __ ] up messed up
meniscus it was all Jarred up and jacked
up but the second that thing got out
dude it was like I was have you seen
Star Wars those those storm things those
those those big [ __ ] um things that
what they called um
they have wobbly legs and they hit like
long robot things yeah the robot things
that's how my leg was
it was it had nothing it was just like a
little dangling [ __ ] like so from my
knee down the shin the tip FIB it just
Tangled like there's nothing and I was
like okay man this so it was worse after
the cleanup much worse like I was done I
went from running 200 miles to I did 240
mile race
in in 2020 October 2020 it was Moab went
out there got second place 62 hours and
he was [ __ ] up getting it drained
before the [ __ ] race but I still ran
240 miles literally five or six days
before the race I'm getting it drained
and it was a baseball-sized [ __ ] um
it's called a baker's assist so they
drained it and I went in there did the
race finished it and I was like okay
here we go went on to do some more races
I did like another 200 Miler did a
couple more races and then like I said
cam came down but after that I went and
got this surgery done and I went from
running every day to now I have some
[ __ ] legs just dangles and after that
surgery this [ __ ] dangling I was like
okay man I'm [ __ ] and just from that
little piece of minutes just that little
piece of meniscus and I'm sitting there
thinking okay man this is not this
doesn't make any sense to me this
there's something [ __ ] I don't
understand why I can't I can't put any
pressure on my leg the the amount of
blood they were taken out was was
unbelievable so there's the blood right
there Jesus Christ that's the blood dude
oh my God it's one two three four and
you see the black blood yeah that is
deoxygenated blood
so whatever was going on whatever the
[ __ ] was going on that's why it looks
different colors so the red blood is the
blood that has oxygen that's right and
that was just like coagulated just
[ __ ] up blood yep Jesus yeah so that
so after surgery I'm like I'm like seven
seven days out of whatever the [ __ ] it
was like and once again I'll know the
exact times but I have them in the book
I have everything [ __ ] dialed in
um I went back and I was like man I'm
I'm [ __ ] up I mean it's a simple
meniscus surgery man like people go back
a week later they're playing two weeks
three weeks tops I'm like man I'm never
gonna [ __ ] run again I'm gonna walk
with the [ __ ] limp so I'm going back
I'm getting [ __ ] like I'm literally
getting my knee drained every week
getting PRP I'm like man that in the
back of my mind I I know how far I can
push myself I know my body so [ __ ]
well so well
and I'm like this is um this is wrong
I'm never gonna run again I'm never
gonna run again I walk with the limp so
this went off about six six months
so I had the surgery done in February it
was uh February March April May June
about four months four months after
surgery four or five months I'm like hey
Jennifer
um I gotta find another you know
somebody else look at my [ __ ] knee so
I try to keep my [ __ ] together but
imagine when you go from every day of
your [ __ ] life grind it
and you go to nothing
like literally like 90 minute surgery
done that's crazy that it was just a
little meniscus scope 90 minute surgery
done
I was like okay man this is anyway so I
found this guy named Dr Gamal out of New
York and we fly there but I'm like
he can't fix this man because I knew it
was a lot more than these it was just it
was all kind of this [ __ ] up body [ __ ]
and I am I'm walking the office and he
decides to see me and me and Jennifer
and then Jeffers happy she's happy as
[ __ ] it's like oh my God man this guy's
gonna be able to get you a [ __ ]
meniscus replacement he was all kind of
gurued out but I'm a realist bro
I will push myself and I'll go as far as
I can but I also am a realist I also
knew the back of my mind I'm not gonna
try to ruin your [ __ ] party Jennifer
that's what I'm saying myself but this
shit's done it's over so but I went just
to pretty much appease her
and just see we know is there anything
left so I walk in the office and Doc's
like uh
yeah I'm looking at your X-rays and
that's the Doctor Who's like I don't
know how this is when the Dr Gamal
looked him up world renowned
[ __ ] dude
and when this guy looked at me straight
faced he said man I don't know how you
did anything
with those knees anything let alone run
200 miles back to back 240 miles where
the [ __ ] you did I don't know how you
did it and so I'm like okay whatever can
we get it fixed
and he didn't want to get there because
he knew I was [ __ ] he's like no you
know we we can maybe you know try and
unload a brace maybe an unloaded brace
will help you out what's an unloader
brace so basically my knee went in on
the meniscus side on the inside so it
was like jamming on the inside so this
braids kind of like it kind of helps
realign the knee a little bit so then
you cannot have so much pressure on the
inside your leg
Yeah so basically I'm like man I'm like
okay I'm not
so this is all you have for me I'm like
you can't do [ __ ] for me and he was like
um no and he was walking out of the
office and he could tell I was like I
wasn't too [ __ ] up but I was like
because I kind of was preparing myself
for the next part of my journey I don't
like to lay in my [ __ ] too long you know
I give myself a couple of minutes say
Okay [ __ ] we got man to [ __ ] up
we gotta get back in this [ __ ] like
what's next you know let's go let's go
see you know let's let's go back to
college let's let's do something because
you're you're running and your athletic
career is done
so
he got the door he opened it and as he
was literally he was shouldered out the
[ __ ] door
and I'm looking at Jennifer I'm like
well you know we'll go back to [ __ ]
you know go back to Nevada and [ __ ]
start again
and he was like
try the unloaded brace out
and there's one more thing we could
possibly do for you
and I'm like
[ __ ] like get your little monkey
[ __ ] ass back in here bro like what
is it like like what the [ __ ] going on
so he was like yeah there's this surgery
called HTO
he was like you can go in we can [ __ ]
you know pretty much break your tibia
it's called high tibia osteotomy they go
in and they break your tibia they they
like slice into it and they they wedge
it to the point where they realign your
leg back up
it's a very painful surgery it's very
painful afterwards painful as [ __ ]
afterwards and they put that plate the
plate you saw
back on and then your leg is so so your
knee is still where it was because this
doesn't get fixed so it takes several
months for that knee to start working
that way back into where that alignment
is so now my leg is just now so here it
is
yeah so they they take a slice out of it
because it's deformed yep and that slice
lowers the part that's deformed and
tries to make it a more natural shape
but you're still dealing with bone on
bone
so you're still deal you're still
dealing with the pain of arthritis
essentially because do you have any
cartilage in your knees not much not
much at all if any so the thing about it
it takes that pressure off of that so it
was complete bone on bone right what
that surgery does is it takes it over to
the lateral side